a journalism non-profit is claiming
several of the richest americans
paid zero income tax in some recent
years
propublica claims to have seen tax
returns showing amazon chairman
jeff bezos the world's richest person
remember made zero payments in 2007
and 2011. meanwhile the world's second
richest
tycoon tesla's elon musk also paid
precisely
zero dollars in federal income taxes in
2018 according to propublica
financial giant george soros also known
as the man who broke the bank of england
paid no income tax over three
consecutive years
propublica reported that the 25 richest
americans
paid a tax rate of just 3.4
percent between 2014 and 2018. that's a
lot less
than the 14 paid by the average american
household
propublica has not said how it obtained
the confidential tax data
the u.s tax authority is investigating
the leak
let's talk about it a bit more though
with our financial correspondence in
frankfurt
chelsea delaney the likes of musk and
bezos paying
zero tax in a year how is that even
possible
well it's possible and it's legal
because of the way that these
uh ultra billionaires are making their
money they're not like normal employees
like
me and you and others who get a paycheck
from their employer and have taxes taken
out of that they
are mostly building wealth through the
accumulation of assets so
getting stock from the the companies
that they're running
from yachts from penthouses from
these massive vacation homes and because
of the tax code in the u.s those assets
are not
taxed until you decide to sell them so
many of these ceos many of these ultra
billionaires are are basically
able to pay very little tax if jeff
bezos has really become the poster child
for this his
wealth went up by a hundred billion
dollars from 2014 to 2018 he paid a 1
tax rate so this is something that's
certainly going to galvanize debate over
the u.s
tax code there have been proposals uh to
sort of change it so that
wealth is also being taxed but for now
there hasn't been a lot of cohesion
among politicians in the u.s about
how how they would go forward with
something like that
okay chelsea delaney in frankfurt thanks
for the update
for more on that i'm now joined by
nicholas shackson of the advocacy
organization the tax justice network
he's based here in berlin so to many
average taxpayers this will likely sound
outrageous even it might not come as a
surprise but paying so little income
taxes is all perfectly legal isn't it
i'm not necessarily actually um there
are a lot of
uh really complicated uh financial
maneuvers that billionaires use
often involving tax havens often
involving um
complex corporate structures which you
it comes down to a judgment call as to
whether
you know the tax authority is going to
accept this and you will often have
these tax
uh positions that they take with these
complicated arrangements
challenged by the tax authority and very
often you will get the tax authority
saying no you pay you're
paying the wrong amount of tax one of
the things that has happened in recent
years in the united states but in many
other countries under a kind of general
anti-tax sentiment to sort of
um the revenue agencies the internal
revenue service in the u.s has come
under attack
um for years and years and years and
it's been demoralized it's been
defunded it's eight you know it's got
fewer and fewer agents
even as you get this proliferation of
wealth and and
um you know use of tax havens and so on
so their their
ability to assess this ability to audit
what rich people are doing is falling
and falling i mean just in 2010 and new
data just came out
saying that back in 2010 98 of
uh big corporations uh tax returns were
being audited
now that's fallen to less than 50
percent so and you're seeing a similar
thing with with rich people so it's
it's it's a real problem and to say it's
all legal is just it's not true
okay nicholas your organization aims for
more tax justice
in the us and worldwide you've mentioned
a few uh things that go wrong what
needs to change fundamentally
okay well a tax you know a tax system is
it touches everything it touches every
economic sector so there's a huge
amount of complexity lots of difficult
things that um that need to be done
if i were to single out one thing
there's no silver bullet but if i was to
think about one thing it would be to
stop this
attack on uh revenue agencies around the
world this reduction in staffing
reduction in head count this
demoralization
that's been going on and i think we are
now at the point where we're seeing this
change we've seen some big changes in
the last few weeks in international
corporate taxation where
companies previous countries previously
been cutting their corporate tax rates
in this race to the bottom
and now we're seeing a flaw to that so i
think you know we need political
momentum behind this we need
voters to come out and tell their
elected representatives that this stuff
needs to stop and it is
happening it takes a long time it's a
very slow process
but we need to stop the attacks on the
revenue agencies and start resourcing
them properly these people you know tax
collectors pay for themselves many times
over
we need to start seeing them resolved
properly and particularly focusing on
the wealthiest individuals and
large corporations so many of the super
rich we've
heard recently say they support higher
taxes in theory
but in practice they're working harder
at avoiding them aren't they
well that's exactly right yeah i mean
obviously there's a lot of hypocrisy it
cost them nothing to say they support
higher taxes i think
you know before 10 20 years ago it was
probably socially acceptable for a
billionaire to say well i just you know
and donald trump has said it much more
recently um you know that makes me smart
avoiding taxes
but it's become more and more socially
unacceptable as inequality has widened
and as people have got increasingly
angry at this kind of
these kind of unaccountable elites and
you know monopolists like jeff bezos
running amazon
um using immense market power to extract
wealth
from the underlying economy um and not
and they're not paying their taxes you
know at least taxes should be part of
bargain
so you know these billionaires it's easy
for them warren buffett
is an example he's criticized um low tax
rates he's famously said i pay less tax
than my secretary
but at the end of the day um he pays an
enormous amount less than his secretary
and he's still doing it
nicholas jackson there the tax justice
network thank you for your time thanks